hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
to quote Barry Manilow it looks like we
made it
50,000 subscribers that's an awesome
achievement for the channel and it's all
thanks to you guys for liking sharing
commenting and subscribing for always
being encouraging for coming up with
lots of great ideas for content and I'm
incredibly grateful to you guys so I
just want to say thanks so much for
supporting the channel and for helping
it to grow this far I thought it would
be a great opportunity to talk to you
guys directly and also to discuss some
of the cool stuff that's coming to the
channel and some of the cool stuff that
you can check out already right now so a
lot of you guys have asked with us any
way you can support the channel and I
massively appreciate that that's a
really kind gesture and until now there
hasn't really been away however I've now
set up a patreon so if you did want to
support the bi-linear help it to grow
then you can head over there and sign up
use it it's my first attempt at that so
I'm still learning I'm going to be
providing some exclusive content to
people who support me over at patreon
just as a thank you and if you're
interested then check out the link in
the description down below and thank you
so much in advance it will really help
it'll help me to invest in better
equipment to make higher quality videos
to do more marketing to reach out to
more people that I want to work with etc
so massively appreciated anything I'll
be incredibly grateful for but likewise
all the usual content is going to be
here as normal don't feel as though you
need to donate money and likewise don't
do it if you don't have the cash I don't
wanna make anyone broke I'll be
providing plenty of free content on here
and over at the bio near comm as usual
so some of you have noticed I'm no
longer the sole contributor to the bio
near we have another very talented
creator called grant Stephens who's an
incredible martial artist and who's been
uploading his videos there's two or
three already available on the channel
right now you can go and watch blender
ton from training with him and from
watching these videos so hope you guys
appreciate that and actually this is the
start hopefully of things to come
I want the bio near to eventually evolve
into a place where you can come to find
all kinds of
intent on self-improvement
self-development productivity
strength training etc I wanted weather
come over here and find this smorgasbord
of different opinions different
experience I also have another new
contributor lined up in their future who
I'll be revealing very soon
we just need to iron out some details
get him a great workflow set up but
hopefully he's going to be contributing
some stuff on body language on
meditation on flexibility in yoga so
that sounds interesting
then that's all gonna be coming here
eventually I might even evolve the
Bayona to become the BI own ears but
don't worry I'm still going to be
contributing just as much content myself
it's just that you'll have a wider
selection to pick from I have a huge
list of topics that are gonna be coming
to this channel soon all the usual stuff
and some interesting new ideas so I'm
gonna be covering the regular kind of
stuff I've got a video on negotiation
coming up I've got a video on next
strengths I've got a video on
hypertrophy and the science of
hypertrophy I'm going to be looking at a
training program you can use to just
maintain rather than gain muscle I you
how much work do you need to do to keep
the muscle that you have I'm gonna be
looking at all kinds of things in
relating to online business and then we
talking about YouTube and how it kristie
YouTube channel if all that content
sounds cool then like I say as always
stay tuned I've got the Bruce Lee video
coming up where I'm going to be looking
at the myth versus the reality and I'm
doing one on fasting right now I might
have uploaded part one by now that might
be a little bit later and then I've got
a part two on that coming soon
intermittent fasting is a really
interesting topic I've also got more
transhumanism content on the way in
particular I'm looking at brain
uploading life extension I'm gonna be
looking at a book called the Nexus and
some really cool ideas that are in there
so likewise stay tuned for that I've
also got the wim HOF video coming up
very soon I know you guys are very
interested in that and the next video
are because we've just reached 50,000
subscribers I wanted to make it
something a bit more momentous do
something to celebrate that so my 50,000
subscriber video is going to be the
Batman training program that I've been
teasing for a while that's going to be
how to train to become like Batman
in theory around the normal routine so
we've looked at Batman's actual training
program what that involves basically it
would kill a normal person so I'm trying
to break that down and create a smaller
more realistic version of that that you
could actually stick to that would
actually help you to get into shape and
develop the kind of skills that Batman
has and the kind of cross modality so if
that sounds cool then stay tuned that we
hear very soon it will be the next video
from me maybe after the intermittent
fasting one because I'm already halfway
through that maybe right away so if that
sounds cool then like I say keep your
eyes peeled and I'm gonna be looking at
some historical forms of training some
different cultures as it relates to bear
training so that means things like ninja
that samurai the Spartans various
different types of wrestling so again
let me know what you'd like to see in
the description down below I've also got
some new whole types of content coming
to the channel that I've been toying
with the idea for a while now and you
guys have helped suggest so I'm going to
be doing legends series so that's
looking at it particularly
high-performing individuals from
throughout history and from the current
day that means people like Einstein like
Houdini like Jack LaLanne like Arnold
Schwarzenegger Bruce Lee looking at
their life looking at the way they train
looking at their philosophies and how
they achieved the things that they
achieved and I think this could be a
really cool idea gonna be doing Darren
brown and because people have been
requesting it an awful lot I'm gonna be
doing book reviews and this is gonna be
very short I'm just gonna be pulling out
a few of my favorite tips from from some
of my favorite books like I say a lot of
you have asked for that and I'm gonna be
doing that here on the channel as well
as over at the Instagram page so if you
don't really follow me on Instagram
please do at the Instagram calm for
slash the bio near there you can also
see my training I upload pictures of
myself in the gym and I provide tips but
I'll also be doing some short videos on
book reviews there and some of my book
reviews will be going to the donators
over at patreon and then finally I'm
going to be trying to do some more quick
tip videos this is overall an awful lot
of stuff I realize and it is hard I have
to dedicate a lot of time to creating
these videos so bear with me but by
doing some shorter content image
longer videos and by having
contributions from other people I'm
hoping I can give you a steady flow of
content whilst covering the usual broad
spectrum of topics that I normally do
let me know in the discussion down below
what you'd like to see if there's any
content that I haven't touched on and
head over to the Facebook page please do
follow me over there if you don't
already I've got a kind of vote going on
a big list of content coming to the
channel and you can vote and let me know
which of those things are most
interesting to you there and then I'll
try and prioritize the things that
people are most interested to see a lot
of my most successful and my favorite
content has been the stuff that you guys
have requested or that you guys have
continuously suggested and by the way
this is the new bio lab like I said I've
got a baby on the way and so I've had to
me about the old bio lab but I actually
think this one is even cooler so ya
might do a video looking at that again
in future so anyways that's all I have
to say for now mainly the main message
to take from this is just thank you so
much I'm super excited about the channel
the way it's been growing and the
website if you don't read the website
regularly then please do you'll find
there there's a lot of content I don't
have time to put into my videos and you
can read it at more leisurely pace all
my references and studies are always
linked in the articles there yeah very
excited about all of it and so grateful
like I say to you guys for encouraging
me for following me etc and making it
all possible and hopefully we continue
to grow this more and more I was at
10,000 subscribers this time last year
the growth has been exponential so let's
see if we can get to a hundred thousand
by mid next year that would be fantastic
and I'd love to get myself one of those
YouTube plaques
if all of this sounds good then thanks a
ton for watching and I'll see you next
time bye for now